wednesday edition pft ot peter king mike
florio here to discuss some of the
things we weren't able to get to or at
least fully developed the way we would
have liked to during that two-hour
program that we completed on wednesday
morning from 7 to 9 a.m eastern on nbc
peter the topic that i'm interested in
today
um it deals with one of the other sports
that is trying to get back up to speed
and you know amid the pandemic which has
has been a horrible situation for
everyone the one very thin silver lining
for the nfl
because it didn't hit during football
season the nfl has the ability to watch
and study and learn from what other
sports leagues will be going through as
they try to restart months before the
nfl has to even begin its season and
what's going on with baseball right now
is very interesting to me because you've
got
the owners and the players trying to
work out terms of a financial
arrangement where they can play games
share revenue which will result in far
less money going to the players than
they're supposed to get under the labor
deal because if they play the games the
players get paid period they've
negotiated their contracts they have no
cause to say we'll take less money they
uh would like to the owners would split
the revenue 50 50. there's gonna be a
lot of pressure placed on the players to
do this and i mention all of it number
one because they haven't worked it out
and number two
this is what's coming for the nfl the
nfl and the nflpa at some point if
there's any adjustment made to the way
this season unfolds if there's any
material change to the working
conditions for the rank and file nfl
player there will have to be a
negotiation between the league and the
union they will have to come to an
agreement and it's quite possible that
the union will say sorry we're not
agreeing and then we get into this pr
battle who's standing in the way of
people having football and these are all
things that we have to be ready for
because what baseball deals with as it
tries to get back on the field we could
see the same things coming up for the
national football league
mike i wrote my column last week that
essentially the nfl is going to have an
uncomfortable non-traditional season
if there is a season and what i mean by
that is that
what everything taught everyone talks
about in terms of fairness
okay everybody has eight home games
eight road games everybody gets to go in
their facility let's say by july 15th
everybody gets to do this it's all equal
that's not going to be what happens in
2020
i think that both teams and players the
league office they have to look at 2020
as a one-off
if you want to play football there are
going to be some things that happen in
this year that for some teams are not
fair
and if
people are going to go to war if the
union and the league are going to go to
war over things like
uh will the 49ers move training camp to
colorado springs i mean and that and
they're not i have no idea what any team
is going to do but i'm saying if team x
moves training camp away for say three
weeks or four weeks whatever it is
and you know there's going to have to be
a little bit of a relationship between
roger goodell and dee smith
to basically say listen some of these
things are going to be uncomfortable
and you know if you're the nfl right now
one of the things you probably say to
the players is look
this new cba is going to work out to be
gold for you guys
you know so compared to what it would
have been and you voted it down
but look all i'm saying is that in
general
teams are going to have to get used to
doing business
in an unconventional way for at least
some part of this training camp or this
season
and i agree with you completely where it
becomes fascinating to me is when they
do need the union to sign off on the
changes that are going to be made
because look whether it gets down to
length of season duration of season
major adjustments to practice routines
training camps being moved if it comes
down to it peter that you know and i
joke about the biodome concept of taking
all teams and putting them in one
location whether it's florida or area 51
where they're quarantined from the world
and they stay there for four months
obviously that's a major imposition on
the life of an nfl player you're taking
him away from his family you're taking
him out of his home he's going to be
staying in some crappy dorm that they
build for temporary purposes for or
whatever whatever hotel rooms they find
in the vicinity of these fields where
they're going to be playing the games
and i guess there'll be plenty of hotel
rooms available because nobody's
traveling but these are all significant
changes to the work relationship and the
union's going to have to sign off and
and that's where the public pressure is
going to be tremendous because we all
want sports we all want football and
whoever is perceived to be standing in
the way of it is going to be the villain
and it could be that the nfl makes the
players a very unreasonable offer a bad
business decision if the union takes it
but the pressure is going to be there to
accept it that's why it's going to be
important i think for all of us who
cover the nfl
to scrutinize whatever offers are made
to understand both sides and to be
willing to say hey you know what they're
blaming the players for standing in the
way here but the owners are the ones who
are being unreasonable and look peter as
it relates to baseball the 50 50 split i
see a lot of members of the media
already blaming the players for not just
taking 50 50. we know what the players
aren't the ones or excuse me the owners
aren't the ones who are taking the risk
of getting sick they're not the ones who
are playing the games i think you could
argue that the players deserve more than
50 50 if they're finding a way to get
this thing done under these
circumstances so i just think we need to
be ready for the issue and we need to be
ready to understand the various
positions that the union and the league
will take when it comes down to it and
we need to be fair with with the fans as
to who's in the right and who's in the
wrong because i think these are all
things we're going to be dealing with
before the first football is kicked
you know i heard something the other day
mike that let's you know talking about
baseball that the boston red sox
basically by not playing a home game
their average home game
in all revenue at a home game they make
about two and a half million dollars
so
think about it
uh that is about over the course of an
81 game season about 200 million dollars
that that team will not be making this
year and so look i am not in any way up
to snuff on any of the business issues
that i've heard
other than the fact that
i think it's pretty apparent that the
teams that do well
at home probably the yankees and the
dodgers and houston and the red sox and
the in those and those teams that really
do well at home st louis
they're going to be losing a gigantic
amount of money and let's if that 200
million dollar figure is correct that
has to come to bear when you talk about
how much money you're going to pay your
players the same way in the nfl and look
it's a lot less
percentage-wise that the gate means in
the nfl because there's only 10 games
eight real games and two fake ones
but there's only really eight dates at
home that you make huge money and so
it's it's less in football but i think
that could end up being a real problem
in baseball and i don't know that
they'll ever get to that point
uh in trying to divvy up the pie in
football
and one of the things to keep in mind as
it relates to the nfl the way the cba is
constructed the way the standard player
contract is written there is nothing in
there that allows the nfl to say to the
players we're not paying you in the
event the season is cancelled which
tells me first and foremost
they will get the season in that's one
of the reasons why they're so determined
to do it because they have to pay the
players anyway but peter also what it
does when it's time to negotiate some of
these alternatives that may pop up the
players have the ultimate leverage
because if they don't like the proposal
that's being made financially to
compensate the players if games are lost
or if if they do a biodome approach
where they move everybody to one
location for the full season which is
highly unlikely but we at least have to
keep it on the table for now
the players can say nah we don't like
any of that go ahead and cancel the
season we'll take our money now look
it's going to wreak havoc on the nfl
moving forward and the salary cap for
next year would plummet but for this
year the players have the power to say
pay us even if they don't play and that
should give the players plenty of
influence when it's time to figure out
the contours and of an nfl season and
you know peter the bottom line is and
and i don't disagree with the nfl's
approach here
but the bottom line is the nfl is taking
one very simple basic public approach we
plan to proceed with the full season
behind the curtain there's a lot going
on and they've done a good job of not
letting it out of not letting it leak
and keeping the teams in line
but you know
this thing can go a lot of different
ways and they're not going to tell us
which way it can go until they decide
this is the way it will go
and you know mike they shouldn't have to
say anything they shouldn't have to say
anything at all and if i were them i'd
be keeping it quiet
the nfl kept it quiet they normally make
uh howard katz and his people available
to discuss the schedule they didn't this
year why of course we know why because
everybody was going to ask about the
hypotheticals they don't want to talk
about the hypotheticals you know the
next step is okay let's talk about these
infection control officers what are they
doing tell us exactly their jobs make a
few of them available none of that right
now and so to me mike
the nfl
is keeping a lid on the things that
right now they don't want to talk about
but eventually
we are going to get to see a little bit
how the sausage gets made because there
will be players involved in these
negotiations with the league and we will
start to hear things we don't hear them
right now but we will start to hear
things very soon
yeah look the clock is ticking and
usually once we get to this point of the
off-season things start to rocket by the
days the weeks the months before you
know it training camps open and we're
going to know something i'd say mid to
late june or maybe not i don't know
maybe they're going to wait till the
last possible minute maybe we won't know
anything we may go through an extended
stretch this summer where we're just
waiting and we're just waiting and we're
just waiting and that's the posture
we're in now the teams are in that
posture and i think the nfl wants to get
maximum information before it makes
significant decisions and look as of
right now and you're the one to talk to
dr fauci there's a lot that's unknown
we've learned a lot about the virus
there's still much more to learn but
there's a long way to go to get to a
point where we can have any confidence
peter about what's going to happen i
hope to hell there's football and it
amazes me to get back to the twitter
trolls that you called out at the end of
the program today when we were talking
about things we've had a lifetime fill
of it's amazing to me how many people
on social media specifically but but
elsewhere
who believe that if you dare to discuss
the challenges that the nfl will face to
get back on the field you are in some
way rooting against football happening
and that is one of the most ludicrous
things i've ever heard no we want it to
happen and one of the reasons we're
pointing this crap out is we hope that
they are thinking of the same things
because this isn't something where we
just say see you labor day weekend and
we're going to play some football
there's a lot that needs to be dealt
with and by mentioning those things
we're not saying oh maybe there'll be no
football this year maybe maybe we can go
without pay too for a full season peter
i mean
the thought that i wouldn't want there
to be football i've covered football
for 37 seasons
and to be honest with you it's the one
thing that really still gets my juices
going i'm almost 63 years old
and you know i don't want to retire i
don't want to have nothing to do this
fall i don't want to be writing about
business all the time and what's going
on off the field and all this other
stuff
i want to be writing about the great
patrick mahomes and
and you know lamar jackson coming to
defend his mvp title how tom brady is
going to do who doesn't want to see
how tom whether you hate him whether you
love him who doesn't want to see how
brady's going to play they put the tampa
bay buccaneers on nine times on national
television this year nine times they
haven't been on national tv nine times
in their existence
so i mean you know to to to suggest that
we don't want to see football that's i
mean it's come on come on baby yeah
peter you me you didn't get the memo
apparently because we as card-carrying
members of the liberal media are
abhorrent of toxic masculinity and we
want nothing more than football to die
even though our livelihoods have been
tied
inexplicably and uh irrevocably to
football not inexplicably what's the
word i'm looking for i don't know i'm
out of gas we've been doing this for two
and a half hours now bottom line is we
love football we want football and we
want to help football identify all the
issues that it needs to identify and
resolve before football can happen in a
responsible and effective way in 2020.
that's it for pftot peter great work
today we'll check out football morning
in america we'll check out the interview
of dr fauci on the peter king podcast
and we'll see everybody back on thursday
for another edition of pro football time
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports